يوم آخر من الصخب في
قلب باريس ، كان يُعتقد أن احتجاجات هذا السبت
قد تكون أصغر بعد أن قدم
الرئيس إيمانويل مقبل
التنازلات الأخيرة فيما بينها برفع
الحد الأدنى للأجور وبعد هجمات ستراسبورغ
الإرهابية ، تحدى عدة آلاف من
متظاهري السترات الصفراء
البرد القارس للعودة إلى  شيانغ أليزيه
جاك البالغ من العمر 66 عامًا يحتج
لأول مرة في حياته. يقول ماكوي إنه
لم يعطنا فتاتًا مما
نطالب بأنه لا يمكننا العيش بهذه الطريقة.
نريد أن نعمل
لإرضاء أنفسنا ليس فقط للبقاء على قيد الحياة ،
كما تقول ، حتى مظاهرات اليوم بدأت
سلمية إلى حد كبير بعد الظهر ،
لكن الشارع كان مليئًا بالغاز المسيل
للدموع وفرصة للرئيس للاستقالة
[موسيقى] ، قام
البعض بتمزيق أحجار الحصى
للمعركة غير المتلهفة للفت الانتباه  وانتشر 8000
عنصر من قوات الأمن
في باريس السبت وهو
عدد يفوق بكثير عدد المتظاهرين
احتجت جيلا على شرطة مكافحة الشغب وأخبرت شرطة مكافحة الشغب أنه
يجب عليهم تبديل جوانبهم وارتداء سترات صفراء
اليوم هم هنا ولكن علينا أن نسأل إلى
أين يذهب هذا ، يقول هل
سيحتفظون به إلى متى يمكننا أن نرى أنهم
متعبون يطلقون النار مقابل لا شيء ربما من أجل
لا شيء سوى إطلاق الغاز الذي فعلوه
هذا هو الفصل الخامس الأسبوع الخامس على التوالي
من الاحتجاجات هنا ولا يبدو
أنه على الرغم من أن الأرقام أقل ،
فإن الاحتجاجات بأي شكل من الأشكال تقترب
من نهايتها ، يمكن أن تكون مرتبطة جيدًا
ثم فعلنا  سي إن إن باريس